vale Indonesia fue el destino del g20 la
reunión de los líderes de las
principales economías del mundo en la
agenda de la primera jornada un tema
opaco a los demás la guerra en Ucrania
presente hasta en el discurso inaugural
bien
ser responsable Aquí también significa
que debemos terminar la guerra
si la guerra no ha terminado será
difícil que el mundo avance
tomo Forward Y es que la mayoría de los
países asistentes como Estados Unidos o
Francia firmarán una declaración
conjunta de condena de la Guerra de
Ucrania un tema que preocupa a todos los
invitados en una ocasión en la que el
presidente de Ucrania voló zelenski ha
aprovechado para pedir que las naciones
del g20 apoyen su plan para acabar con
el conflicto con propuestas como la
creación de un tribunal especial para
condenar la agresión de Rusia que está
reconozca la integridad territorial de
Ucrania o el intercambio total de
prisioneros y habló de un g-19 en una
Clara exclusión de Rusia
estoy convencido de que ahora es el
momento de que la guerra destructiva
rusa debe y pueda detenerse
algo que Rusia representada por el
canciller ser gay en la brop en la
Cumbre interpretó como la negativa de
Ucrania al inicio de las negociaciones
todos los problemas están en la parte
ucraniana se niega categóricamente a
mantener cualquier conversación y viene
con condiciones obviamente reales e
inadecuadas para esta situación
[Música]
una situación que se ve con preocupación
desde el g20 que ya ha asegurado va a
firmar una declaración de condena de
cualquier amenaza de uso de armas
nucleares por parte de cualquier bando